[Musique]
pour mon dire ça va commencer
marca
tu avais aucun droit
entrez dans la danse la magic en ce sens
là
maraka bras
à tâtons et quiz et à un taux de cas qui
est vrai alors attention tu n'as pas
vraiment celle question n'est pas ma
montre un pas du tout la com
attaquants 13 avant choisi celle que tu
sois non non non non non tu t'en
souviendras tu peux très bien
non alors d'un coup tu me le dis je n'ai
aucun mérite à n'en dit pas j'espère que
ce n'est pas de toi ce sont ici
non non sûrement pas
je mélange tout et maintenant pour
retrouver cette carte
ce n'est pas moins je ne vais pas du
tout faire de manipulation ou à essayer
de retrouver dakar d'une façon d'une
maman pas du tout j'ai apporté un
appareil qu'on appelle un stéthoscope un
corps image est ce que tu vois je peux
placer cet appareil sur mes oreilles et
pourquoi tu penses à dakar entre dakar
se détrompent nombre de coups dans
l'ajout de près bien cet appareil
particularité si tu mens il te fait
grossir ton et non non non non non
j'espère que je n'ai pas de trêve car
maintenant la carte grâce à la magie a
été retrouvée d'une façon tout à fait
originale le regard n est plus dans le
jeu mais dans un petit porte-monnaie que
j'ai là un petit portefeuille
elle est passée mystérieusement à
l'intérieur
car il suffit de l'ouvrir et tu vas voir
rattraper les formidables car à
l'intérieur
à importuner se transforme en une sorte
de cabas un sac jeudi
abracadabra et regarde l'intérieur du 5
le roi de carreau qui était bien sûr la
carte rate un truc que tu avais choisi
le roi de carreau
oui 88e 2 13 moi je m'appelais de très
beaux schémas l'enrichir en blanc
maintenant je comprends
il est dû
[Musique]
vous
tous
[Musique]
on
art
des bains
on est petit enclos
[Musique]
jean ping
jean ping pong mais bon ma fille soit
une petite moitié pour la chine
[Musique]
cachez des choses vous attendent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
or à distance et qu'est ce qu'il ya j
soins tu as soif via attends tu permets
un nom mais je vous répondrais quelque
chose de beurre regarde il n'y a pas un
verre mais deux vers qui était l'un de
l'autre
dakar est alors si maintenant on prend
le liquide d'un verre repasse dans
l'autre on peut aussi avec ses verres
faire un tour ah oui il garde toujours
avec la même formule vous la cage et
abracadabra et on arrive à sortir de
l'eau un fou la voilà mais oui j'ai
encore se met donc au pardon bon bah
écoutes je crois que vous avez été assez
gentil heureux je vais vous l'expliquer
alors si vous voulez faire si vous il
vous faut trois gobelets patois 3
regardez 1 2 3 alors ces trois gobelets
le premier ou le découper à peu près à
cette hauteur comme ceux ci tout le tour
et vous obtenez un tout petit globeleq
dakar et ce petit gobelet écouter pour
vous rendiez mieux quand j'ai pris un
doublé transparent de niveaux records
avec un peu de ruban adhésif pour le
fixer à l'intérieur vous voyez d'un
autre gobelet bien sûr non transparents
là c'est pour que vous puissiez voir
ainsi le petit gobelet ne doit pas
arriver jusqu'aux bords comme cela tu
vois james un petit peu de différences
sont à peu près 3 4 mm comme ça on ne
verra pas le foulard qui lui va être
placé prendre entre le vert et le petit
gobelet secret ici avec l'appoint d'un
ciseau ou un stylo peu importe voulu
placer à l'intérieur
donc quand tout est rentré vous êtes
prêt pour débuter le tour vous faites
couler l'eau toujours bien souvent le
petit gobelet et après il n'y aura plus
qu'à sortir le petit foulard d'accord tu
as bien compris
je crois que tu l'as déjà montré devant
ta famille tu m'as un raconter une
petite histoire qui m'amusait beaucoup
tu veux m'en faire oui d'accord
et vas-y fais rien car les truites chic
à la carte donne un gobelet offerte en
tout
bon ben alors moi j'ai apporté un petit
photo né le lord maire tient bien puis
alors je verse un petit peu d'odeurs sco
viola attention puis dans l'autre il y
des deux puits dans l'eau il y avait
même des petits poissons un foulard
précédent des poinçons adéquation les
poissons de mer rouge
ah oui mais l'autre mais on peut pas la
boire un ancien magistrat
en quelques mots j'en serai bon alors il
est des petits poissons et si tu as
toujours cela pourrait prendre deux
verres vides mais on va essayer quelque
chose mais je ne suis pas sûr de réussir
en dix ans abracadabra on peut essayer
quelque chose avec ces deux aires
attention abracadabra et la regarder en
rogne les grenadines
alors la rigueur des avants dans l'agora
jean charest c'est formidable y en a
vraiment au lendemain d'un gain dé c'est
formidable richesse et le sensationnel
le rocher c'est pascal qui est épuré je
choisis la blanche
[Musique]
oui mais non kinder und sohn traction
moi ça va
attention bruits trop coûteux oui oui
tant que tu t'en fous tu es habitué à
des doctrines pour que tu es
[Musique]
auj
on
[Musique]
[Musique]
ans
e
oh
ton petit y est oui non monsieur le
chinois est ce que vous ne pouvez nous
prêter ce merveilleux appareils passée
de rafraîchir les français risque
électrique
ils vivent mal de patente en patates
d'état bataille des écoutes
quand gérard va arriver très bien très
bien
quand gérard sera là qu'est ce que vous
faites là encore à quai ce que j'étais
en train de mijoter
nous répétons un tour de cartes dans les
quartiers avec des cartes géantes
regardez bien pris par sa série cart
n'importe quelle soit pas le savoir la
partie croise un jeune walser you la
regarde
c'est très important bien alors garder
la ligne la carte dans la poche est rare
dans la poche et maintenant ils
s'installent ici et moi je vais trouver
la carte ce qui l'a choisi
c'est là le lobe le le cadre de drive
tirage et par grille cadre de travail
parfaitement thézac voilà et d'en haut
mon oeil c'est un peu facile à on peut
le faire avec vous et avec 52 cartes par
jour et par sens fait essayer d'aller
voir alan hely alors l'un des foulards
jeu politique
vous prenez une carte n'apporte la cage
à celle que vous voulez voilà qu au nom
et aux faut pas regarder un nom vous
regardez bien la cape est assez
attention vous mettiez la carte dans la
fente lorient le 20h dans la poche comme
je venais il dit
d'accord vous installer la l'accord là
là vous allez voir c'est un tour très
piquant
oui bon je m'ai fait avec vous voir dans
les yeux
[Musique]
c'est un drôle de tour de cartes que
vous avez fait ce n'est pas très gentil
pour gérard os non je veille sur lui
abracadabra walker un préalable à la
hausse il a fait
[Musique]
c'est malin o o
e
à l'approché
[Musique]
quoi
je ne mens
pour la
[Musique]